first of all was it right over the
gathering and down the street cabinet
arrived for their weekly audience where
they ought to hear what matters to this
government in the days ahead i've not
been invited to anybody
right now that's the least of the
problems facing the chief whip and his
colleagues are you embarrassed that the
government is being investigated by the
police leaving number 10 these cabinet
ministers discovered that they were
amongst the last in the country to find
out that britain's most senior police
officer had just said this the mat is
now investigating
a number of events that took place at
downing street and whitehall
in the last two years
in relation to potential breaches of
covet 19 regulations
she made clear the fact this involves
boris johnson was critical
there was evidence that those involved
knew
or ought to have known
that what they were doing was an offense
this is what a blind-sided cabinet looks
like do you think it's embarrassing that
the government is being investigated by
the met police for having downing three
parties watch these cabinet members as
they try to find a car to take them the
short distances back to their government
department simply to avoid the cameras
they know they're ill-prepared to talk
about the story that will dominate
government for weeks to come do you
think the prime minister can survive a
police investigation this man is one of
forest johnson's chief parliamentary
aides he's got to find some kind of
favorable spin to placate tory mps was
the matter discussed in cabinets mr
griffiths
not commenting on anything to do with
that today while even those around the
top table were speechless as they got to
grips with the news i think it's
absolutely right the met will do their
job
can you survive the police investigation
but with russia poised for a possible
invasion of ukraine the prime minister
was forced to head to the commons today
where the opposition were on the
offensive
potential criminality has been found in
downing street
what a truly damning reflection on our
nation's very highest office
still plenty of tories lining up to
defend him 10 minutes of eating cake and
wishing someone a happy birthday would
not a party make but it is a matter for
police investigation can we please have
a sense of proportion over the prime
minister being given
[Applause]
being given a piece of cake in his own
office boris johnson even suggested to
the commons a police investigation that
clears him would be helpful i welcome
the mets decision to conduct its own
investigation because i believe this
will help to give the public the clarity
it needs and help to draw a line under
matters despite what some tories might
try and tell you there is no universe in
which boris johnson being investigated
by the police for potential breaches of
lockdown rules
is anything other than a big blow
his own official appears to have found
evidence of criminality which she's
referred to the police
but what if boris johnson leaves office
the government will continue in all
eventualities
continuously in a stable way but i think
you're getting ahead of yourself uh
we'll wait for the outcome of the
inquiries have you broken the law prime
minister
questions about this man's future coming
to a head indication of the su-gray
inquiry could be imminent how long will
this be home
samcotes sky news westminster